Can Texas separate from the union?
America's second most populous and second largest state is there to remind you
that it was once an independent state: the Republic of Texas.
Unlike California's three-week, incidental flirt with independence (and horrible flag)
the Republic of Texas was a real country with its own presidents, laws and currencies
for a decade, from 1836 to 1846, when it joined the union to become the 28th state,
and to make the number of stars happy again.
This happy marriage almost immediately led to the Mexican-American War about the question
how big Texas was. America, being the winner, was allowed to choose the answer: very big.
While Texas gave up its independence to join the union, they gave them independence
did not write down - and filed their divorce, along with a number of other states, just under 15 years later.
This domestic dispute was not settled with flowers, but with force, something that many
are grumpy about today.
But history aside, in modern times could Texas still become a real country? In other words:
Will Texas succeed in seceding?
In terms of population, an independent Texas would be the 46th largest country
with 26 million citizens. And those citizens would make Texas the 13th largest economy.
Thus, the New Republic of Texas would be comparable to Australia, except for the size.
But what happens to the federal money that goes to Texas? Building interstate highways
not yourself, you knew. For most of the states, independence would be a financial one
be a problem. Mississippi, for example, gets two dollars from Washington per individual being
sends taxes. Thus, an inevitable Magnolia republic would almost immediately fall.
Except Texas, which gives more money to the federal government, than it gets back.
There is no reason why Texas cannot leave its highways paved * and * their population
to give a small happy Texafhakigheidheiddag tax reduction.
So, from a financial perspective, the New Republic of Texas would have an advantage.
Now the question is; can Texas secede legally? And the answer is ... no ... not at all.
In spite of popular belief, even by politicians, who should know better, the Texas Constitution includes
no leaving-union-no-obligation clause how much like Texans, or residents of
other states, wish it did.
Although, the Texas Constitution has a weird clause that gives itself the opportunity to self
to be divided into five states without the approval of Congress. So Texas can explode into any moment
the states probably called: North Texas, South Texas, East Texas, West Texas, and Austin. -- which
his strength in the Senate would increase fivefold - but not necessarily help to gain independence
because there is no legal process for a state to leave the union.
Although the constitution is silent on that issue, separation should come before the Federal Supreme Court
and shockingly enough, the Federal Supreme Court of the United States has decided that states should
Cannot leave the United States.
But the legal question is a strange kind of dispute. Finally, the first Texas Replubliek
didn't just happen - Texas was originally a state of Mexico, which is Texas
did not give permission to leave, but Texas did, or less harmoniously
circumstances.
While a war between the New Republic and Texas is hard to imagine, is
it's not hard to imagine who wins that fight. Texas has its own army, but seriously,
no one beats America in war.
So the only way for Texas to leave is to convince the United States to be
to change laws to allow it. Which would only have the chance as a majority
wants independence from Texas, which is not the case afterwards.
So while a New Republic of Texas is interesting to think about - especially for some non-Texans,
from now on it's a long way to reality.